i want to talk about red lists and amber
lists
because well you know one of the big
questions at the moment is we have this
variant this new
indian variant spreading around the uk
and one of the suspicions in fact one of
the likelihoods is that it came in
uh on flights from india and one of the
questions is
why was india not added to the red list
sooner we know that pakistan and
bangladesh were added to that red list
which means obviously you have to do a
hotel
uh quarantine also if you're not a
citizen not a resident you can't come to
the uk
we know that india the pakistan and
bangladesh were added uh early in april
second of april was the decision
um why was india left off for so long
well here
is what the health secretary matt
hancock had to say about that uh just
earlier on
and the truth is that when
we put pakistan on the red list and
indeed
bangladesh the positivity of those
arriving from pakistan and bangladesh
was
three times higher that from india
that's why we took
those decisions and here's the thing i
want you to remember three times
higher and he said this is the truth uh
about the evidence they were seeing well
it certainly
might be matt hancock's truth but you
know if we look at the actual data
there's a different truth we'll talk
about kind of
who's truth these days this is what the
data that was collected by the nhs the
test and trace suggests around that
period end of march
early april when bangladesh and pakistan
were added
to the red list and i've got india in
there as well and you can probably see
there's a difference isn't there
look india 5.1 positivity rate so
basically 5.1 percent of those
tests coming back positive pakistan 6.2
that's not three times higher nowhere
near three times higher and look at
bangladesh actually below
india when it comes uh to that
positivity rate
so i don't quite understand what matt
hancock was talking about maybe he has
other data that he hasn't shared with us
but this is the government's own data
collected by test and trace
which covers precisely this period 25th
of march to the 7th of april
that we're talking about two weeks
before india was added
to the red list so it just it just looks
odd i just i can't
frankly understand it uh maybe we'll
hear more from the health secretary
about it
uh in the coming days and weeks but
nonetheless that's that's
one bit of the data they were looking at
prevalence so looking at how much covert
there was in these countries to try and
get a sense of whether people should be
allowed in
uh or not but they're also looking at
something else variance just how many of
these variants of concern
there were in these countries at the
time actually the weird thing by the way
about that matt hancock statement is at
the time that
uh those countries were put onto the red
list um
we were told it was all about variance
we weren't told it was about positivity
but anyway
leaving that aside doesn't seem to be
quite in tune with what he was saying
let's look at variance and the
proportion of those tests this is
remember this is just travelers coming
back from these countries the proportion
of those tests that were testing
positive four
variants of concern you can see a lot of
them in bangladesh so i wonder whether
actually
what the health secretary meant was
really the bangladesh decision was about
variants whereas it wasn't
for pakistan but look at india right in
the middle there and more than
half of all of those tests that have
been sequenced from india
coming back positive for variants of
concern two weeks
two weeks before the decision was taken
to put it onto the red list
and when you consider that there are
more people coming from india than
indeed from bangladesh to this country
the sheer number so we're talking about
number of people bringing variants that
have been detected
was higher in india than either
bangladesh or pakistan by a long way in
fact actually when we look at all of the
countries
or places where variants were detected
coming from india
at the top of the list so more variants
coming from india than anywhere
else in the world two weeks before it
was added
to the red list but this raises a kind
of broader question doesn't it because
clearly a lot of the focus right now is
on india and why it wasn't added
but there's also a question about what
is the rationale anyway for this red and
amber
decision how are these decisions made
and if we look at the countries which
are on that list and just
rank them uh by the positivity rate so
again
the higher these bars are the greater
the level of positivity
uh in these countries when travellers
came across
and you'll notice something odd look at
the colors so the the ambers like the
yellowy ones
those are the amberliest ones obviously
and the red red bars are red list
uh countries and it's not entirely clear
what the pattern here is is it so for
instance okay
look at the very top molly yemen very
high levels
of positivity there in molly and yemen
actually around 20
of tests coming back positive is odd in
many senses by the way because a lot of
the data coming from there is not very
reliable so this gives a better sense of
what's really going on in those
countries
big outbreaks uh it seems but
nonetheless look they're still
on the amber list whereas countries like
angola for instance the drc democrats
republic of congo
are on the red list so what is the
rationale there it's it's
not entirely clear to me it's not clear
for instance
why the uae has lower positivity than
most places in europe that's been on the
red list for a long time
but you can see just look how far down
it is on this on this kind of ranking of
just how much
covert 19 we're detecting and travelers
coming from these places
really very low uh indeed or by the same
token i mean there's some rationale
for some of these decisions look at
philippines very low level of not very
low but low by the standards of these
bars
low level of positivity uh but a 75
percent variant rate so 75
of those tests uh coming back positive
for the variance of concern so that's
the concern
uh with the philippines so that makes
sense but in that case
why not put ghana on the red list that's
on the amber list it's got
higher level of positivity so more
covered prevalent
and more variants coming back from ghana
so
there are some weird things going on
here and the problem really is that the
government hasn't published its
methodology about why some countries are
red and why some countries
uh are indeed amber um india is a clear
example of
of it but there's as you can see
questions across the board
uh there when we find out more about it
we'll let you know but for the time
being the government a little bit
unclear about how these decisions are
being taken and in the meantime let's
talk about the indian variant we know it
is starting to spread
elsewhere around the uk we can just kind
of zoom in to different parts of the
country
for instance uh bolton 210 cases uh in
the past
two weeks uh i might just actually show
you this is it's a chart similar chart
that i've shown you before but it is
worth bearing in mind have a look at
this we're going to
break down those cases and this is all
cases so not just the ones with the
variant
uh by age and look it's going up very
sharply indeed
uh in bolton for under 60s
but here's the thing that's under 60s
okay and that's kind of varied across
that
age group now have a look at over 60s
and that's pretty flat isn't it so
that's quite encouraging
that's quite encouraging because that
suggests there might well be the gap
between those two things
there might well be a bit of a vaccine
effect and we'll continue to monitor
particularly that bottom
uh that blue line at the bottom to see
whether that starts to rise it is rising
but there's just such a gap between
the two of them suggesting those
vaccinations people over 60 of course
more likely to be vaccinated those
vaccinations do seem to be working
against this variant whereas for under
60 it's going up very sharply indeed
but we know as well it's not just bolton
we know actually in bedford we've got
50 cases in the past fortnight as well
and the suspicion is
it is spreading it is spreading around
the uk but worth just looking and seeing
if we see the same pattern because that
would be encouraging wouldn't it uh here
in bedford you can see that cases of
uh covered for under 60s and remember
these are all cases but we're getting a
sense here that a lot of these
are the indian variant under 60 is going
up not half as fast
uh as we saw uh in bolton but now look
over 60s and again the gap is opening up
so that's pretty encouraging same thing
from there
uh as we're seeing uh in bolton as well
um and finally it's worth just
underlining
all of what we're talking about here is
happening within this very tiny area you
can see on the far right this is just
total number of cases
the very tiny number of cases uh across
the uk down to the lowest level
certainly since last
summer um and that is the encouraging
thing really even if this variant does
indeed spread around the uk
provided this chart remains relatively
low
that is good news but we're just going
to have to keep an eye on that uh in the
coming weeks and also just frankly try
and understand
why these decisions are being taken
about read and indeed amber
list countries will bring more to you on
that when we understand it ourselves